DeSantis is saying you know get out of  this place fetterman is saying we should  count these guys that signature is not  being counted uh uh Carey lake is  telling voters go for Maricopa County to  Phoenix because Phoenix is more liberal  none of the machines were having issues  the other ones were having issues some  people are waiting in line three four  five hours these are the types of things  that get people to say if we have  technology the way that we do today why  can't we make this more compliant clear  easy that we can trust you know in  Florida whatever you vote you can go on  a website look at your vote to track the  two see if it was counted or not State  of Florida does that wow you know how  many states you can do that in not many  in many states you can't even figure out  if your vote counted or not you don't  know it's just kind of like did they  counted or not ah just trust us we got  it